black widow should have been well into
our rear view by now alongside
several other mcu phase 4 flicks but the
covet 19 pandemic delayed the film
leaving us with a big screen drought
but now the movie's new release date is
finally fast approaching
here's everything we know about black
widows so far
black widow had an original premiere
date of may 1 2020 but it was pushed
back
three times as theaters remained closed
across the globe
the scarlett johansson lead flick was
moved to november 9
2020 then again to may 7th of this year
fans were further disappointed when it
was announced this march that black
widow would be delayed one more time
this time to july 9th the movie isn't
expected to shift again as things are
finally looking up regarding the ongoing
global health crisis
most theaters in the united states have
reopened and mass mandates are being
lifted as millions of americans are
getting vaccinated for those still
feeling
unsafe about heading back out to the
movies black widow will also be
available to stream on disney plus the
same day that it's in theaters
subscribers to the platform will have to
shell out extra cash
to watch the movie as it will only be
accessible via premiere access for 29.99
black widow is a prequel story for
natasha romanov taking place between the
events of captain america civil war and
avengers infinity war
we know that some of team cap are on the
run from the united states government at
this point in time after steve rogers
broke his pals out of the raft prison
while natasha was famously on team iron
man she eventually found herself in the
middle
as she aided stephen bucky in their
escape from the airport battle in
germany
unfortunately for her black panther told
secretary of state thaddeus thunderbolt
ross about what natasha did
forcing her to leave the avengers and go
on the run then in avengers infinity war
we learned that she eventually linked up
with steve
and sam wilson and the trio helped
rescue wanda maximoff and vision at the
train station in scotland
as for the 2021 film black widow is
expected to explore the missing
chunk of natasha's life between these
two films which eventually sees her join
up with steve and sam
natasha romanov will link up with some
of the most important people from her
past in black widow this will include
her surrogate family members yelena
bulova played by florence pugh
molina vostikov played by rachel weiss
and alexis shostakov aka red guardian
played by david harper from stranger
things
from the trailers it looks like elena is
going to be the biggest supporting
character of the bunch serving as
natasha's
sister who was also trained in the red
room elena is a spy just like her sister
and she's also gone by the black widow
moniker in the modern era of marvel
comics
many are suspecting pew's character will
become a bigger presence in the mcu
after black widow given her character's
rich history in the comics and due to
the fact that she's set to appear in the
upcoming hawkeye series on disney plus
according to the direct melina and alexi
are mother and father figures to the
girls but they aren't their biological
parents both are also
highly trained and skilled in combat
which was apparent in the trailers
despite alexi putting on a little bit of
weight since his glory days
but as for what we know about their
comic book origins red guardian first
showed up in 1967's avengers number 43
where he was the soviet union's answer
to captain america
weirdly enough he was originally black
widow's love interest although that's
obviously changed for the film
as for vostakov she goes by the name
iron maiden in the comics and she made
her first appearance in 1983's marvel
fanfare number 11
where she was incredibly resentful of
black widow's legend and eventually
became her sworn enemy
there are a few other stars who've
joined black widow in some pretty
noteworthy roles
for example ray winston will portray
drakoff a name
mcu fans might remember from the
avengers when natasha romanov is trying
to lure
information out of loki while he's
imprisoned on the helicarrier
can you wipe out that much red
drakov's daughter the mention of the
name makes natasha go wide-eyed
instantly letting viewers know the
mystery man is bad news from her past
and from the black widow trailers we've
learned dracoff is the superior of
taskmaster and
oversees the notorious red room
additionally ot fegbenlei will be
playing rick mason
someone we assume is pretty important
given he was honored with his own
character poster for the film
rick is one of natasha's only allies and
he apparently has a romantic interest in
her
anything else we can expect from rick in
the movie is a mystery but fagbenly
commented on the character in an
official black widow movie book saying
mason is a finder for people who aren't
so affiliated with armies like people
who are part of the underworld he can
find anything you need as well
he's had a relationship doing that work
for the black widow and they have a bit
of a vibe going on
there's a sense that there's more to
their relationship than it being purely
work related so that's always in the mix
the talent behind the camera on black
widow is just as impressive as the
talent in front of it
the mcu film is directed by kate
shortland who's mostly known for her
films berlin syndrome
lore and somersault black widow is
easily shortland's biggest feature to
date given its 200 million dollar budget
plus jack shaffer and ned benson make up
the writing team of black widow marking
the second official mcu project for
schaefer
the writer famously penned all nine
episodes of wand division which was
praised by critics and fans alike black
widow marks benson's first project with
the mcu
and it's the newest addition to his
rather short hollywood resume
the writer is mostly known as the scribe
and director of the disappearance of
eleanor rigby
while we know the aforementioned dracoff
is going to be playing an important role
in black widow the movie's true villain
is taskmaster somehow after leaks and
multiple release date changes the
identity of taskmaster is still a
mystery but fans definitely have their
theories on the masked baddies real name
who the hell is that guy first appearing
in avengers number 196
taskmaster was a former shield agent
turned assassin whose birth name was
anthony tony masters
taskmaster has the ability to mimic any
opponent's combat skill
which almost always gives him the upper
hand in a fight however
we're not expecting the black widow
taskmaster to be tony masters but rather
someone natasha already knows
this person appears to be some sort of
russian agent who's also in charge of
the red room
and we're suspecting it's someone we've
already seen in the mcu or possibly one
of the newcomers we meet in black widow
is it rachel vice could it be otf
bentley we'll find out soon enough
so taskmaster's whole thing is mimicking
the moves of other superheroes like this
cool spider-man web swing and by
watching the trailers we've discovered
that the big baddie has been doing his
homework in one of the trailers we
watched taskmaster wield a bow and arrow
kind of like a certain avenger we all
know and love
he's even got black panther's claws it
also looks like he's learned a few moves
from captain america with lots of shield
work on display
taskmaster also mimics a famous natasha
move flipping up on one hand and one
knee from a supine position
how he learned her move is a mystery but
natasha definitely has her work cut out
for her if she's essentially fighting
herself
based on the trailers we know thaddeus
thunderbolt ross will be showing up in
black widow william hurt appeared to be
de-aged in his brief trailer appearances
which makes sense given the last time we
saw him was at tony stark's funeral in
avengers end game which was set in 2023
given the timeline of black widow ross
will be around seven years younger
what exactly his role is in the new
movie remains to be seen but he could be
trying to track down natasha after the
events of captain america civil war
tony stark is also expected to make an
appearance in black widow based on a
report from deadline back in 2019
downey's cameo in the movie is expected
to be just that so fans shouldn't expect
much of a storyline from the now
deceased hero
someone else we expect to show up in
black widow is contessa allegra
defontaine
who we met in the falcon in the winter
soldier played by julia louis-dreyfus
according to vanity fair valentino was
first set to appear in black widow but
with premiere dates being pushed back
due to the cobin 19 pandemic things had
to change
whether val will appear is still a
mystery but we know marvel studios does
have big plans for her moving further
into the mcu
with black widow constantly being
delayed over the last year in an effort
to keep fans interested
marvel studios gave us additional
trailers sneak peeks and
featurettes all of these were majorly
dissected as fans did their best to spot
all the easter eggs they could and there
were definitely quite a few moments
people
and objects that stood out in many of
the clips we were shown
some of which might hint at the movie's
biggest reveals one of the cityscape
shots in the trailers was that of
budapest a famous city in mcu lore that
we've never visited before in the
franchise the marvel fandom knows the
hungarian capital well
solely based on comments from natasha
romanov and clint barton in the avengers
and avengers end game we know the
friends have a history in budapest but
just what went down between them or
whatever mission they might have been on
is still a mystery
we also get our very first sneak peek at
little natasha romanov which saw her
alongside a young elena bulova and their
adoptive father alexi
this was well before the girls went to
the red room which we learned about in
avengers age of ultron it looks like we
might see the terrible moment where the
young girls are sent off to be mind
controlled against their will
eagle-eyed fans have also noticed that a
vest yelena belova is wearing in the
trailer is the same one we see natasha
sporting in avengers infinity war
this suggests that black widow could
directly lead into the third avengers
film with not much time in between the
two
when it was announced that black widow
was going to be a prequel some fans were
disappointed since it might not bear any
weight in the mcu
but remember this is the first movie in
phase 4 and you can expect it to
introduce us to new characters who will
stick around moving forward we are fully
expecting elena bulova to be natasha
romanov's replacement in the mcu much
like we saw anthony mackie become the
new captain america in the falcon and
the winter soldier
we're also expecting a little more
backstory on clint barton
but still aren't sure about a possible
cameo taking us to budapest is almost a
confirmation that hawkeye will at least
be mentioned in the movie especially if
taskmaster has memorized his fighting
style
this is all a great tease as to what
we'll also see in the disney plus
hawkeye series and while just a rumor at
this point black widow could also very
well set up the thunderbolts in the mcu
both baron zemo and thaddeus ross have
ties to the group of reformed
super criminals which is currently led
by taskmaster in the comics
black widow is going to be so much more
than a prequel and fans of the marvel
cinematic universe should be extremely
excited for the film we've waited far
too long to see check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one